it's up to you the balls in your [ __ ]  court no more [ __ ] around you want  your life to be better I can't help you  we can't help you Joe Rogan can't help  you already can't help you God can't  [ __ ] help you only you could [ __ ]  help you grab your [ __ ] balls  get a [ __ ] notebook and write down  what the [ __ ] you gonna do this year and  this is it you're not gonna have these  problems  [ __ ] the drugs [ __ ] the cigarettes [ __ ]  that dumb [ __ ]  it all starts [ __ ] today alright no  more [ __ ] excuses that's the [ __ ]  this is the year of the [ __ ] soldier  it's 2015 we're going in like [ __ ]  Marines you understand me 2015 we're  getting back what belongs us and that's  it no more [ __ ] around play the  national anthem Lee I'm sick of these  [ __ ] let's go the good one -  which shoots and [ __ ] people missing  legs I want to hit a good one Lisa yeah  it's over that's it it's over